How's it going Jacksepticeye fans?
It's me
-And me
*smol giggles*
Thank for having me!
We are Eastern European boys.
Apparently so, I was slav squatting on ground.
*laughs in slav*
We like disco, vodka
and Adidas.
-and Adidas.
[Giggles]
But my favourite is
the Jacksepticeye and Pewdiepie
collab videos.
Some of the best content ever on Youtube platform.
You spit on me.
Im sorry you want me to lick off?
YES YES
(CHRISTIAN CHANNEL)
But I thought for our epic collab, we're gonna look at
all the other epic collabs.
Through the years
SEPTICPIE (whut?) *whispers* through the years
Septicpie
If you didn't know this
I gave this guy a SHOUTOUT.
I don't know if you heard about this.
whaaaaaat?
This is craaaazy!
And actually
I wanna give my second shoutout
hahah-second shoutout
The anual shoutout
Check out JackSepticEye. He's a Youtuber, who makes gaming videos
You were in it for..
6 Years
suh-SEVEN YEARS
Almost seven. Now you stopped the flow.. Alright
SORRY!!
Too much (G-FUEL)
USE CODE: PEWDIEPIE FOR 30% OFF
-HURRY!
Our first collab
How long was that?
5 Years ago?
WAIT!
June 2014! It's almost been 5 years, since the first time we- DAAAAAAAMNN
You did the shoutout before that though
I was like, I don't know who this guy is. Yeah,
and i tweeted at you like: Thank you so much Pewdiepie uwu
This is so amaaaazing uwu
And then.. no reply
You didn't like it, you didn't tweeted me back ;-;. And then
A couple of hou- a while later we got into this collab
together and you were like
"Oh this guy!"
*Big HAHA*
It's funny cause it's exactly it.
I mean- I didn't see you tweet or whatever
No
The thing is i shouted out so many people
Yeah
Uhh and then
You shouted out like 12 people
Yeah and i just forgot about you
I just remembered: Oh it's the loud Irish guy!
The guy who says top of mornin"
Wow! We should play game now
Where are you?
I'm- Are you in this?
OHhHHHHhh!
There you are! There I am!!
I pop in
I don't have heal powers
WOW! That's ME!!
I remember this..
AwWWw This takes me back
That was fun. Yeah
Can i get in on- You know what this means? We cross streams bruuuh
We cross streeams
We had such a flowing chemistry
And we're already making joookes
WOOOW!
**Death glare**
I like this-iss-uh back then when you put the microphone
HEY GUYS WELCOME TO COLLABORATION
maybe you did
Hello everyone
Yeah for everyone who's trying to wonder why
His aud-er Video quality sucks these days
is because you went from having shitty audio quality for like 4 years to
And then you morphed into crappy video quality
Well not now
Cause you're using my set up
Yeah that's about right
This is June 25th
And then after that
Collab after collab after collab
It was just a non stop steam train
It was non- I don't think we collab after that
I could not find anything else
From 2014
And this was June
OH! You left a little comment
And i thumb- you thumb up your own comment
OwO
That's so cringey
I think- 4 years ago
Well to be fair like a lot of times
if you  don't, It won't even be shown up anyway
*Synchronized Comment Reading*
Ugghhhh that's sooo...
That's sweet. You didn't wanna be like
You didn't even pin it! Go back and pin it! Go back and pin my comment right now!
You can't pin back then
Go back an pin my comment right now!
It was literally not a function
There's so many times
when I find videos that I watched
years ago and I'm like
"Oh, I remember this video"
And I go to and I lea- I left a
ReALLy CRiNgy comment
(insert sample comment from past)
and I just Delete the comment then
because it's TOO BAD
-Focus Switch-
I love it
and I peen it
Oh my God
-Focus Switch-
GO TO THIS VIDEO NOW
My comment there's at the top!
loo-
*VICTORY YELLS*
WE DID IT!
Yeah-ha-ha-hay
Loved and "Pinned By PewDiePie"
I'm gonna add that to my notice thread on Twitter
*BIG JAJAJAJA*
So then we played
GTA V
(Released 26/4/2015)
GTA V was fun
This was a time where everyone was
Playing video games together
Yeah
It was so easy to collab cuz
You had Gmod(love it) GTA...
This was before GTA Roleplaying was a thing
*dismissive pewds affirmation*
Now everyone's obsessed with GTA again
Honkydonk- *silent laugh*
Brah-- AHHHH
See I care about Q U A L I T Y
*laughter* HEY I LIKE YOUR VEST (GEAR?)
Clearly your mic stopped working because you use the camera audio
I think that's the mic actually
I think it's a used (B Mic?)
I have no idea what's happening
Man, we could do and say whatever we wanted
back then (MISS THOSE DAYS)
It was the Wild West back in 2015
5-minute videos
Truly was the Wild West
*nostalgic sigh*
All you needed was a...
good soul.
This has 7 MILLION views
That's pretty crazy
We also collabed in- What else did we do?
OAhh the BroKen Podcast
OOOHHHH
You were a guest on the BroooKen Podcast
You were #4
(ohmy)
god- Pre-Green Hair
*pause*
PRE-GREEN
Pre-Green Jack
Welcome to YouTubers React with Pewds and Jack
Is that WHAT YOU DO KEN?!?
K: That JackSepticEye-That's what I do
Whenever I get out of these calls with you guys
I, like,  go and call someone EeeEVIiiLlLl and I'm like
Oh meh Geeed- I just talked to JackSpedicey
and- then- then- the-
Nothing's changed with Ken
B̷̛̘͉̭̬͇͆̑̈͌̊̄͆̋̋͆̐͑̋͜I̷̢̛̯̲̫̠̦̰̫͓̳̲̳̰̠̘̒̊̈́́̃͑̀́̌̈̈͗͒̽̀̈̅́̓̉̇̈́̚͘͝͝G̸̡̰̲̯͖̹̜̹̬̘̝͈̯̪͙̲͈̈̓̉̓͐͑͋ ̸̧̖̎̆͋͆L̸̛͕͉̣̦͇̩̞͕͙̘̝̙̳͛̊̍̀̊́͑̃͌͝Ā̷̛̯̤͙͑͌͊̑̍̈͆̄͋̔̊̀͋̌̄̉͂͌͊̿̕͠U̴̢̨̥̹̗̻̠̥̼͇̹̦̲̜͙̰̤̙͙͇͕̥̗̬̙̘͉̬̿̈͘ͅĢ̶̢̢̯̲̪̖͇̘̲̫͍̳̼̺̙̳̤͚͔̭̼͉̀̈́͊͐̂͑̒͂̏̓̈́͒͛̈́̌͋́͒̍͌́̿̾̀̈́̚͘͝͝͠͝H̷̡̼͇̥͔͕̠̃͒̽̑̈̊̒̚͜͝ͅ ̶̡̨͇͎̮̣̱̦̱̭̰̬̜͕̟͓͕̦̗̮͛̀͌̊̓̏̔̋̐̃̇̔̎͂̏̉̂̇̐͆̈́͘͝Ṁ̶̨̡̪̝͍̰͈͔̰͕̠̜̺̣͓̻̩̭̗̤̀̀̾̿̀̄͌͐̆̿̽̀̏̂̊̈͒̈̉̓̅̔͋̈́͒͐̏̒̎͠Ờ̴̛̭̠͎͎͙͕̼̳̮͕͎̥͊̾͒̆̓̋̅̒͊̒̔̈́̔̃̒̀̉̒̋̉̅̒͘̕̚̕̚͝͠͝͝M̸͙̆̂̄̇̃̄̽̀͐̍̾̾̈͊͜Ȅ̷̢̢̧̡̢̧͓̭͕̠̻̖̬̙͔̰̱̒̔̓̀̍̋̀̃͑̄̂̚̕͜Ň̶̢̡̜̯͖̫͓̺̙̘̖͍̣̗̝̲̃̌̍̿̽̈̀̒̅̆̾̓́̏͌̑̔͘̚̕ͅT̷̢̡̨͎͔͎̼̳̜̤̜͙͇̞̯͍̮̩̙̖̼̱̼̀̾͐͐͜͜͜͠͝ͅͅ
Except he-
he just does this on Twitch now
*Reads Comment*
I think people thought you guys were in the same room
*Moment of REALIZATION*
And I was, like,
On a call or something
you think so?
I don't know
LOOKWHOIVEFOUND
GREEEN HAAAIRR
ohmYGOD
GREEEN
HAAAIR-
me and the boys
*chuckle*
Me and the bois
hehe's so bad
FELIXKJELLBERG
_________________
ZERO DEATHS
That was when Alexa had just come out
Yeah, you added a BLACK DILDO to it
Yeah I did- No, a HORSE DILDO
See? Clearly I'm a great friend
and you remember
*weird fluctuation* all my jokes
Oh- I clickbaited you
In the....in theeee
This is when I came to Brighton- yeah
Was this when you came to Brighton?
Yeah, first time-
PDP: This is before you moved there?
yeah
*car honk*
This is the first time I came to Brighton.
My first visit.
This is a weird era
all 9-Year Olds salute your leader Felix captain of the s.s. wheeley boi
This is so cool- look at all your toys!
...
I'M SORRY- ACTION FIGURINES
Thank you.
This is when you got, like,
the Ruby Play Button and everything
This was before 50 million
*wheeze*
I like how- I was like- okay Jack
is coming down- I'LL VLOoOG
That will be good video
Well, that was cuz I was gonna cone and dis r u p t your whole schedule
It was like, I need to vlog so I actually get
videos done today
ooohhh
So I was- I-I was interrupting
your work flow
That You
Tuberrrr grind, man.
I see you
Then Marzia brought me round to the antique store
Oh really
Brought me to see the pier
OH REally?
...OH YEAH we hAd RrrrAmen
Yes!
Old Jack: ooooh GuUuURlll
OJ: Did I make it awkward?
Old Pewds: You always do
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA-uhhhhh
it's true- Nothing has changed
*TWINKLE*
Oh, CLASSIC
THE JACKSEPTICEYE ROAST
I-I pointed out thaa-
Look up my one
cuz I pointed out that it has
the same amount of views almost
Me when I see bishops in the restroom
dude
*EPIC MUSIC*
Yours is funny- no yours is funny
(so nice)
Hey, Jacksepticeye
I bet u think we're bros
just cuz we HANGOUT
I bet you think we're straight up d-
HOMEDOGS
Just cuz we hugged once
Well GUESS WhAt?
*Felix questions his choices*
I hate my dog, and I HATE YOU TOO!
I love that- like, I hate my dog on camera
Prepare to get flamed-
It's a known fact
B I T C H
Yeah I did "B I T C H" for everything-
Do you want some tissues?
JackSeptic-BYEEE
BRUUHHH
Hey Jack
*Looks at script*
When I first saw you,
I GaAaAgged
why would i say that
JACK
Your facial hair
makes you look like a prepubescent member of ISIS
*EPIC ROASTING*
*LITERALLY*
You cannot joke about that
You keep making fun of my
hair...
No
Because you wish
you had this hair
*SPITS ON SETUP* bitch
WTF?!?!?
Your abs looks like a vagina
So I have to BLUR it-
BLUR THAT Skit
Why were you showing your abs?
Hey Jack
It was a waxing challenge
This is what your fans think u look like
but this is what you really look like
That's the ULTIMATE roast
That- THAT came back recently
Which is convenient-
-In one of my videos
Really?
Where I mentioned the green Dove deodorant again
*Little Potato Man*
Geddit cuz ur irish '
(outofmyfaceskrub)
I like how you spent effort
doing that
then you said some nice things-
I love you <3
Awwwwhahaaawww
You would never ever say that to me again
Everything's uploaded today- let's see what all my
FRIENDS
are uploading, cuz I need to
FRRRIErNDS
-actually watch them,
See what all my F R I E N D S are uploading
-sooo, ookay..
...Uummmm,
This part as well
-alright, well what do we have-
wait
... the **** is this *rehash*
-On the PewDiePie Roast, it shows I watched it already
You couldn't do incognito?
No
*still a rehash*
Why did mine get so many dislikes?
Cuz yours was the first one
So I think people were reacting to it
Being like, "How dAre You sAy It?"
oh i see
Not realizing that we had messaged each other being like,
"Should we do this"
Oh, that's it.
That's IT.
*Classic Lopsided Glasses Clip*
Oh, it's ON
This is like current YouTube still
With glasses worn awkwardly
-You look really strange
Hey PewDiePie, haha
more like
PewIWishYou'dDie
BRUHHH
You say I have a prepubescent beard?
Well maybe I just don't wanna grow one
as long as yours that makes me
look like a FREAKING homeless person.
INTENSE BASS
bruh
the longest laugh from Pewds in the whole video
the longest laugh from Pewds in the whole video maybe
yeah no contest
Did you just roast YOURSELF
Yeah, I did.
In the future?
*moans in pain*
Good job
-By trying to roast me?
bruh
-Bruhhahaha
Brad gave me some, uh...
I know he did
(BRADNOTE TM)
Hey Swedish Boi, I've got some furniture over here
that I'd like ya ta build
no
-You say I look like a potato
You say this is my family
ANGER
I eat this Shticky for breakfast
Potato crunch
cuz ur irish
*vomits potato like a man*
I had to go out and buy potatoes
for this video
I think I did too
I didn't have potatoes in my house
I was like,
"Shwiffer, no places are open that are gonna sell potatoes
right now, but I wanna make the video
*Potato Rain*
So you were like
"Okay, I'm gonna pour"-
-Yeah, I need to ABUSE them
At least I don't look like a hairy Swedish meatball.
GOT EM
Hey Felix,
you have 44 million subscribers
Where's all the views bro?
That's real
-Where's all the views?
*That one still hurts
That hurts us all
22 million subs- where's all my views?
yeah
You think that I- copy YOU?
Hey Felix, when are you gonna start uploading in 1080p
or 60 FPS?
NeVERRR
That was my one
That was my (ULTIMATE) roast
It's so stupid, like
Who gives a Shtungle?
Well, clearly, you knew what to...
hit on.
Yeah- Your views and your upload
I WOULD show you what you REALLY look like
Except it's against Terms of Service
To pull down my pants and show my ass to the camera
I thought you were #1 on YouTube
That's a good roast
Why are you trying so hard to be a watered-down Filthy Frank?
*Synchronized BRUHHHH*
That- That was- That was- That cut DEEP
You think so?
I like how- as well- it was like
"You think I copy YOU?"
It was like, "We all copy each other now"
right.
Everyone copies each other on YouTube
Do you remember this video?
*reads title* OH, this is the
This is it
-Pants on fire
Do you hate me?
Yes.
*BIG LOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLLOL
What is it?
-Truth
I KNEW IT!
FUCK U
-Holy shunning
Do you like having cream on your face (kinky)
yeah
REALLY?
oh
-You're INTO THIS?
I thought you hated creams
-What is wrong with you
*I guess
It didn't work! Come on
No, it didn't.
We found out afterwards that the guy was lying
for a lot of them.
ReAlLy?
You heard it here first folks- I'm the best YouTube channel
EVER
Every YouTuber thinks they're the best.
Yeah, that's-
-Every YouTuber thinks they're hot sticks
We agree on that one
Did you dye your hair...
Because you were jealous of me and Mark?
I don't know what to answer
Did you dye your hair 'cause you were jealous of me and Mark?
no
*sharp intake*
WTF?
Jury says no, bro
-no fun way,
fix you
-You jealous of my hair bro?
I AM NOOOT jealous of your hair
-You wanted a piece?
Why do you think I'm covering it up? What, did you think I wanna
look like you? No one wants to look-
AAHHH
(lil bitch pewds) you slapped my fAaace
I was supposed to hit your hat, but I full-on just
BACK-SLAPPED YOU straight in the face
I'm so sorry
I went just full-on bitch mode
right a mo- right away
Listen to me
*INSTANT REPLAY*
you slapped my face
YOU FRuskIn BITCH- YOU FU- ayyy
Yeah you hit me
-2019 PewDiePie would
never react like that
It was a lie
-No
*Why do I look like I'm crying?
What does it smell like?
because you are.
Okay fine, I'll admit it wanna be-
-Smell it.
I wanna be-
-Smell it!
-SMELL IT!
I wanna- *sniff*
*POMF*
eyy
-That was so uncomfortable
what?
Being, like, trapped like that with cream all over your face.
I couldn't breathe half the time.
-oh
Oh YEAH! cuz you had to PFF
Yeah
-yeah.
And here we are today. No- We're at 2017.
oh god.
Oh- IT'S the SAME ROOM!
That was a weird video.
That was a fun video.
And then we just stopped collaborating in 2018.
I know.
-What happened?
It's cuz we had falling out.
We had a big fallout
Big backstab and big no friend no more
You went to L.A.
I did. I went to L.A. for 3 months
And I went on tour.
I was barely in Brighton for all of
last year.
-yeah, that's true.
This is fun
-Hello and welcome back to WHISKEY
Me drinking W H I S K E Y. I am joined here today
With famous Irishman
-Me drinking whiskey
I'm really good at intros.
It's like, you know what to say, but
your brain just can't keep up with it.
We've gotten so much- like-
people kept saying we were
idiots in this episode
cuz it was like- Aged 14 Years
and I was like, "It's 14 years old"
Ohh, the proof- yeah, yeah
And then everyone was like
"That's not what it means,"
And then it went full-circle and then
All the whiskey people went, "Well, technically-
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
And then people called 'em out.
GOT EM
So weird. Thank you, whiskey aficionados
Well that was all our collaborations
throughout the history.
Please can this one get 25 million viewz
That would be great.
Yes, please!
And-
-More views, more subs
As always...
Use Code: PEWDIEPIE to get 10% off GFUEL
SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR SPONSOR Free